with permission mr. speaker I'd like to
make a statement regarding the full
opening of our schools and colleges to
all pupils in September I know these
past three months have been some of the
most challenging that schools parents
and most of all children have faced what
schools have achieved to make sure that
children and young people are kept safe
and can continue to learn during this
period is remarkable and I think in this
house we're all deeply grateful for
those efforts but we all know the impact
that lost time in education can have on
our children's outcomes every child and
young person in the country has
experienced unprecedented disruption to
their learning as a result of
coronavirus with those from the most
vulnerable and disadvantaged backgrounds
amongst the hardest hit education
recovery is critical for this generation
of school children returning to normal
educational routines as quickly as
possible is critical to our national
recovery - that is why we've been
working to ensure that all pupils will
be able to go back to schools and
colleges full time in September with
kovetz secured measures in place so that
they have the opportunity to thrive and
fulfill their full potential today the
government has published detailed plans
for nursery schools and colleges that
set out what is needed to plan for a
full return as well as reassuring
parents and carers about what to expect
for their children the guidance has been
developed with medical experts from
public health England and follows
regular engagement throughout the
outbreak between the government and the
education sector we continue to work
closely with the country's best
scientific and medical experts to ensure
that both children and staff are always
as safe as
schools will continue minimizing contact
between children including through
grouping children together in bubbles
and encouraging older children to
distance outer men minimum this will
mean keeping whole year groups in
schools and colleges separate this is in
addition to the other protective
measures that we know are so important
for infection control such as regular
cleaning and hand-washing
we're also ensuring testing is readily
available so that parents teachers and
students can return with confidence all
staff pupils and their families will
continue to have access to testing if
they develop kovat 19 symptoms by the
start of the autumn term we will provide
all schools and colleges with a small
number of home testing kits these will
be taken home by children or staff who
developed symptoms while on site but who
would struggle to access a testing
center this is so that they can have a
test quickly and they can get the
results back quickly all the schools
will have access to direct support and
advice from their local public health
England health protection team to deal
with any cases that may occur they will
be advised on what steps need to be
taken mr. speaker in these challenging
times we are committed to ensuring the
nation's children have not just a safe
education but also an excellent one from
September we are asking schools and
colleges to return to a broad and
balanced curriculum so there's all
pupils continue to be taught in a wide
range of subjects maintaining their
choices for further study and employment
we expect exams to go ahead in the
summer of 2021 we understand the
additional pressures on teaching staff
to deliver such high standards of
Education in this day
period as such as Ofsted inspectors are
preparing to visit schools in the autumn
it will be to discuss how they are
managing return to full education of all
their pupils the insight that inspectors
gather will also be aggregated
nationally to share learning with a
whole sector but government and the
wider public it is our intention for
full inspections to return from January
we're also providing significant
financial support to help pupils catch
up on lost learning as I announced in
June we'll be providing a 1 billion
pound covert catcher package including a
650 million pound ketchup premium for
state-funded primary secondary and
special schools and a 350 million pound
national tutoring program for the most
disadvantaged pupils evidence shows that
6 to 12 weeks of tutoring for a
disadvantaged pupil can result in five
months of catch-up schools are held
accountable for the outcomes they
achieve with their funding including
through Ofsted inspections and Vuckovich
catch up funding will be no exception to
this it is critical to ensure that no
child loses more time and education and
that from September all children who can
be at school are at school schools and
colleges will need to work with families
to secure regular attendance from the
start of the new academic year with the
reintroduction of mandatory attendance
our intention is that those with
education health and care plans or
special educational needs will also be
back in school or college in September
since May as a result of a pandemic it
has been necessary to modify the duty on
local authorities and health
commissioner's so that they could
they're reasonable endeavors to secure a
range for provision of EHC plans and
committed to removing these
flexibilities as soon as possible
so children and young people can receive
a support they need to return to school
as such unless the evidence changes I
will not be issuing further national
notices to modify the EHC duties we will
however consider whether any such
flexibilities may be required locally to
respond to outbreaks in different parts
of the country in addition I am pleased
to announce that as we continue on the
road to recovery and infection rates
continue to fall from the 20th of July
nurseries child minders and other child
care providers will no longer be
required to place limits on the group
size of children who can play and learn
together mr. speaker I'd like to take
this opportunity to thank those parts of
a sector who've already opened their
doors to more children and who are doing
a phenomenal job to help our children
and our young people settle back into
their usual routines since schools and
nurseries began to open more widely on
the 1st of June we've seen the number of
children attending school steadily rise
with over 1.6 million pupils already
back in school I'm sure mr. speaker I'll
be joined by the house as I expressed my
thanks to all of a childcare school and
further education staff who have gone
above and beyond since March and who
will continue to do so as we prepare to
welcome all of our children and young
people back to school and college in
September
I commend the statement to the house